[Musique]
c'est avec détermination qu'il s'engage
dans l'armée et prête serment un moment
particulièrement solennel cette année
pour ses jeunes soldats et leurs parents
dans la caserne Julius les beurre à
Berlin la guerre en Ukraine et dans
toutes les têtes
l'invasion russe en Ukraine a ramené la
guerre en Europe
franchir la porte d'une caserne n'est
pas anodin vous vous en êtes bien rendu
compte ces dernières semaines
un changement d'époque qui s'accompagne
d'une nouvelle ambition pour l'Allemagne
de venir la plus grande armée
conventionnelle de l'Europe au sein de
l'OTAN un fond spécial de 100 milliards
d'euros a été débloqué par le parlement
allemand pour remettre la boule de svers
à niveau pour ces jeunes recrues qui
rejoignent le Bataillon de la Garde
faire carrière dans l'armée prend une
toute autre dimension à 17 ans Yoann
Klein a trouvé sa vocation
pour la discipline pour venir en aide à
tous ceux qui en ont besoin et préserver
la paix
je suis fier de lui même si j'étais un
peu angoissé au début par cet engagement
dans l'armée mais je sais qu'il est sur
la bonne voie
mais pour l'armée allemande le chemin
sera long matériel vétuste lourdeur
bureaucratique et soldats démotivés
selon un rapport parlementaire la boum
de svers est dans un état alarmant de
nombreux experts estiment qu'elles
seraient incapable de défendre le pays
en cas d'attaque
pour le lieutenant
l'électrochoc provoqué par la guerre en
Ukraine a donc quelque chose de
salvateur
nous allons être rééquipés avec de
nouveaux véhicules des munitions et tout
ce qui s'ensuit nous allons recevoir du
matériel plus moderne beaucoup de choses
vont changer on est dans un processus
nécessaire de régénération
la Bundes 180
000 soldats disposent de milliers de
postes non pourvu alors tous les moyens
sont bons pour recruter la série YouTube
consacrée au quotidien du Bataillon de
la Garde fait un carton près des jeunes
très présente sur les réseaux sociaux la
bundeswerle est également dans les
salons pour l'emploi elle reste
l'employeur préférée des lycéens
allemands juste après la police on a un
domaine militaire pour ceux qui veulent
devenir soldats mais aussi un domaine
civil l'armée propose plus d'une
centaine de formations civiles ou
militaires
dans l'informatique les sciences
sociales
mais aussi des métiers qui nous amènent
sur le terrain comme la médecine
personne ne souhaite que le pire arrive
mais si c'est le cas je pourrais venir
en aide aux gens les soigner je serai
prête à faire ça pour l'Allemagne
dans les mois qui ont suivi le début de
la guerre en Ukraine le nombre de clics
a doublé sur le site de la Bundes verts
deux tiers de la population se dit
désormais favorable à sa modernisation
[Musique]
alors 22 ans après la réunification
allemande et la fin de la guerre froide
la réserve de l'armée était à l'honneur
aux célébrations de la fête nationale à
airfourt la réserve qui suscite un
nouvel engouement je veux rejoindre la
réserve pour être utile si tout parents
susceptent pour aider par rester assis
dans mon canapé
l'armée allemande dispose actuellement
de 31 500 réservistes qui viennent
renforcer ponctuellement les forces
armées actives de passage pour une
petite revue de troupes informelles la
ministre de la Défense Christine
Lambrecht souligne leur importance
grandissante
nous entrons dans une époque où il est
plus que jamais nécessaire de protéger
les infrastructures critiques mais aussi
de développer une forme de résilience au
sein de la société en ce sens les
réservistes remplissent une mission très
importante
alors que le service militaire a pris
fin en 2011 ces hommes et ces femmes
sont appelés à endosser toutes sortes de
missions sur le territoire allemand
les deux chiffres la boule de svers fait
état d'une augmentation des candidatures
personne n'aurait pu imaginer que
quelqu'un change les frontières d'un
pays à notre époque avec une telle
violence computing l'a fait
on voit bien que cet événement a changé
la donne d'un coup l'intérêt de la
population pour les capacités de défense
de notre pays et bien plus important
mais dans un pays qui a cultivé sa
tradition pacifiste depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ce soutien pour
l'armée s'inscrira-t-il vraiment dans la
durée pour l'heure en tout cas tout
semble indiquer que les mentalités
évoluent selon cette spécialiste de la
défense
on aurait pu craindre que la crise
énergétique par exemple pousse les
Allemands à retirer leur soutien à
l'Ukraine et bien pas du tout c'est un
signe qui montre que de nombreux
Allemands ont bien compris ce qui est en
train de se passer et que c'est vraiment
tout le paysage sécuritaire de l'Europe
qui a changé
un changement d'époque qui ne fait que
commencer selon des experts il faudrait
jusqu'à 8 ans pour remettre à niveau
l'armée allemande ces équipements et ses
effectifs
[Musique]